[intro]
Hello, everyone! And, welcome to the Psych2go YouTube channel. I'm Ashley, and I'm one of
the main members of this channel. You may have seen me from videos such as, 'Nailbiting: A
Problem Deeper than Skin Deep' to 'Benefits of Singing and Music Therapy'.
Now, if you're new to this channel, what we do is we feature videos contributed by our lovely
community of followers who wish to further explore the content from our main website,
Psych2go.net.
Today, the topic is: Why do we get the best ideas in the shower? And, I'm here with Psych2go
today to talk about anti-social behavior versus asocial behavior.
We make videos based on the community contributed articles on the website.
"I'll be going off the article, Art Therapy by Dancia Cecilia"
"All eyes on me, the spotlight effect by Jenny Kang"
"Today's article is about people tend to sleep late tend to have a higher IQ by Risha Mae"
We have videos talking about 10 psychological facts about human feelings, to articles debunking
psychological myths.
"So today, we're going to be talking about 5 harmful myths about mental illnesses."
Our videos come in 3 formats. Whiteboard animations, such as "10 Benefits of Being Shy".
Casual vlog style, such as the one you see me do. And, in the future, our third format will be
taking on interviews of psychology professors.
Now, if you are interested in contributing to our little channel, then feel free to send us an email
at psych2go@outlook.com letting us know a little bit more about yourself. And, once again, I'm
Ashley. If you have any questions, don't be shy. Let us know in the comments below. Feel free
to send me a shout in my Tumblr page. I'll shout back. I hope you've enjoyed our content here.
Have a nice day!